the cuban authorities have prevented the
country's most prominent opposition
leader junior garcia from leaving his
home in havana for a solo protest
the operation came the day before
marches planned across the country to
demand greater freedoms and the release
of political prisoners a protest the
government has declared illegal
garcia said that every cuban should have
the right to demonstrate peacefully
i think that is my greatest aspiration
that every cuban knows they have power a
lot of power that a single citizen can
make a system tremble
the cuban government has organised a
number of counter demonstrations and
last week called hundreds of foreign
diplomats to a meeting to accuse the
united states of being behind the
protest
washington's representatives in havana
were not invited
and this video aired on state television
accuses yunya garcia
of working with the u.s authorities and
anti-cuban organizations
claims he strongly denies
the planned marches on monday coincide
with cuba reopening its doors to foreign
tourism
closed for 20 months because of the
covet 19 pandemic
restaurant owner carlos marquez says the
return of tourism will help the
country's battered economy he called the
opposition demonstration a distraction
i'm sure it won't happen sure
sure from the moment they started
planning it it was a crazy idea
tens of thousands of cubans think
otherwise they belong to archipelago a
movement organized on social media it
grew out of protest in july which took
the authorities by surprise due to their
size and spontaneity hundreds were
arrested
[Music]
growing dissent is being expressed in
other ways too this video by musician
roberto carcasses is called no one can
stop me
authorities will be better prepared to
repel monday's planned marches and the
threat of violence will keep many away
although he said even if the protest is
suppressed the opposition movement will
keep growing
for the first time in nearly all the
provinces in the country the people have
come together to cry for freedom that's
historic symbolically it marks the
beginning of the end
it's a prediction made prematurely many
times since fidel castro came to power
in 1959.
the difference this time is the
protesters are staying in cuba to fight
for change rather than leaving and
that's a challenge the cuban authorities
are struggling to deal with
daniel schweinler al jazeera